I'm talking about verification of
quantum computations the question I'm
addressing is whether a classical
computer can verify the result of a
quantum computation in this model I'm
going to assume the output of the
quantum computation is classical so the
quantum computer is solving a decision
problem and the classical computer would
like to verify whether the output is
correct or not the first problem which
comes up immediately is that quantum
computers compute in superposition since
the superposition can be over
exponentially many bit strings this
means that the classical description is
exponentially large this immediately
eliminates the possibility of the
classical computer simulating the
quantum computation and checking by
comparing the output to his simulated
output the next issue is that classical
access to a quantum system is extremely
limited the classical machine can only
see measurement outcomes so although the
system might be exponentially complex
the classical machine can only access n
bits of information at a time I'm going
to be looking at this question through
the framework of interactive truth in
2004 Daniel goddess Minh asked if a
classical computer can verify the result
of a quantum computation by interacting
it with it over many rounds this is
called an interactive proof and in this
setting the classical machine is called
the verifier the quantum machine is
called the prover and the verifiers goal
is to only accept the provers answer if
the prover outputs the correct the
correct output of the quantum
computation so the first thing you can
ask here is whether the classical
results concerning interactive proofs
hold in this setting so in classical
complexity theory interactive proofs are
well studied but the model is a little
bit different the verifier is still an
efficient classical machine but the
prover is now an all-powerful machine in
this model it's known that IP equals
pspace which means that all problems
which can be computed in polynomial
space
can be verified by a verifier
interacting with an all-powerful proving
the issue here is that although bqp is
contained in P space so this tells us
that the verifier can verify bqp if he's
interacting with an all-powerful prover
I'd like to ask whether this is possible
if the prover is not all-powerful but
just an efficient quantum prover okay so
since this question was asked in 2004
it's been well studied but the model was
relaxed in two different ways
in the first relaxation the classical
computer was allowed access to a trusted
quantum computer so he had his own
quantum computer a small one maybe a
couple qubits and the question was
whether he could use his small quantum
computer to verify the result of a
general amount of computation so it
turns out that this is possible and the
work was initiated in two different
lines of work one by Broadbent
Fitzsimmons cash EFI and one by Jerry
Michael Benner and a lot of money the
idea here was that the verifier could
use his small quantum computer to
perform some type of encoding on the
qubit then he could send over this
encoded qubit to the prover and because
the prover didn't know the encoding the
verifier could track the prover
throughout the computation and ensure
that the prover behaved honestly so he
uses a small quantum computer to produce
qubits and send them over and then the
rest of the communication is classical
and then in the other relaxation been
talked about this earlier this week the
classical verifier is allowed to
interact with to prove errs instead of
one so he can test them against each
other
this was also shown to be possible by a
paper by Rhett cartographers arani in
2012 and the rough idea here is that the
verifier can play a game with the to
prove errs and if the provers pass with
a certain probability the verifier is
assured that the provers share certain
states and he can use this guarantee to
force the previous to carry out a
computation in this talk I'll go back to
the setting where you have a classical
computer and a quant improver and here
I'll use post quantum classical
cryptography to allow the verifier to
control the behavior of the bqp prover
so the verifier will use the fact that
the bqp prover cannot break this quantum
secure cryptography in order to force
him to perform a computation to do this
I'll require a specific post quantum
crypto primitive called trapdoor claw
free functions so first let me define
what this is it came up briefly
yesterday but I'll define it again here
okay trap tower claw free functions so
the first thing is they're 2 to 1
there's a trapdoor which allows for
efficient inversion so given a point
given an image Y the trapdoor allows a
party to extract both pre images of Y
next property is claw free so a claw is
two pre images which map to the same
point and claw free means that it's hard
to find a claw so it's hard to find a
pair of pre images which map to the same
point so a quantum secure instantiation
of a trapdoor a claw free function was
created in a paper with Zika Paul Tomas
and diminish
and the main advantage the reason that
Raptor claw free functions are so useful
in the quantum setting is because a
quantum computer can sample an image Y
and he can create the corresponding
superposition over the clock now as it
stands this isn't that much of an
advantage because a classical computer
can also sample a random X 0 and the
corresponding way the reason this turns
into an advantage is because the quantum
computer can use this superposition to
sample a string D which satisfies this
linear equation ok so because of this
advantage
trap door claw free functions can be
used by a classical verifier to test a
quantum prover the advantage is this
linear equation so he first creates a
superposition of a random claw and then
he can sample a string D which satisfies
this equation and we don't know how to
do this classically yeah so the quantum
machine can do this just given access to
F
okay so given this advantage you can
come up with a way that the verifier can
test a quant improver yeah for the
trapdoor you're given Y and some extra
information otherwise that contradicts
the hard no because he's not finding
across right huh
so I'm saying it's hard to find a club
but here you're just creating a
superposition of something else it's
fine that all you are not even given why
you don't have the trapdoor yeah it's
right the chart door and everything is
easy if you don't have the trapdoor then
you can't find anymore
I don't this makes you a question
there's something interesting here which
is that hard to find a claw this is
assumed to be hard but when you're
writing you know is it the one computer
and do something images right right so
this is much weaker than finding a claw
he's just finding some parity
even this setup the verifier can test
the quantum proof yeah
once you sound whole another question
once you sample this D do you have
access again to the same cloth yeah
because it ruins a superposition so I'll
show you in a second how you actually do
this how you create the superposition
and sample D but you can only do one you
can only hold one all right
so given this setup the verifier can
challenge the quant improver and the way
he does this is he first selects the
function f and he asked approver to
produce an image y and then he at this
point he already has leverage over the
prover because once the verify receives
why he can use the trapdoor to compute
both inverses but the prover cannot
compute both inverses because that would
be finding a claw given this leverage
the verifier can test the prover in one
of two ways in the first challenge he
just asked for a pre image of Y and if
the prover behaved honestly he then he
has this superposition and he can just
report it and he'll pass it in a second
challenge yeah so he can measure the
state in the standard basis and report
and he'll hold either X 0 or X 1 in the
second challenge he can ask for D so the
string D not satisfied that linear
equation and again if the previously
this is possible this format this
challenge the verifiers challenge of the
prover was first used for randomness
generation and the idea here is that
there's a we have a hard core bit
property for our trapdoor law free
function which says it's hard to hold
both a string a D which satisfies this
linear equation and one of the two pre
images so that means if the prover is
passing this test that I just laid out
then he must be he can't be
deterministic because if he was
deterministic he could hold both and
violate this hardcore bit
okay so that's how the setup was first
used and now I'll be using a similar
structure but I'll be using it for
verification instead the Hoover were
able to learn both that you could just
you know get the freedom adjusts or just
the fine cause um we don't quite prove
it you can find a claw but we're just
proving that it's hard for him to hold
both so what we show is that if he holds
both he can violate some learning with
errors assumption do use that I mean you
know if you could get many DS for the
same X 0 and X 1 then of course you're
going over it right well here you don't
do it every time I say it's different
units for different I say ok cuz these
all seem like very special hardness
assumptions we're saying
okay so I'll use the same setup but for
verification instead of randomness
generation so here instead of proving
that the prover is probabilistic I'd
like to use this to constrain the prover
I'll use an extension of the approximate
chapter law free family built in the
randomness paper but I'll need a couple
more properties which is where I use an
extension so I require the Hardcore a
bit property that I just mentioned and I
require one more hardcore bit property
it's written here but it's not necessary
to understand this now I'll mention it
again later okay so now let me go back
and say how you create a superposition
over a claw and how you sample a D which
satisfies the linear equation so the
first thing is the bqp machine can just
create a uniform superposition over the
domain then he can apply the function in
superposition and then you can measure
this register to obtain Y at this point
he holds the state x0 plus x1 because
the only remaining elements of the
superposition are those that correspond
to Y now how do you obtain the string D
you just perform Hadamard transform on
that state so the result of the Hadamard
transform is this state and the only D
with nonzero amplitude are those for
which d x0 x or x 1 equals 0
so once he performs Hadamard transform
and measures he obtains a D which
satisfies this when you're English
okay now I'll tell you the outline the
first thing we'll do is I'll define a
measurement protocol the measurement
protocol ideally is supposed to behave
in the following manner the prover is
supposed to construct an N qubit state
row of his choice the verifier chooses
one of two measurement bases for each
qubit and the prover should just report
the measurement of row in the chosen
basis this is the ideal operation and in
the second I'll define I'll define the
measurement protocol the next thing
we'll do is I'll link this measurement
protocol to verifiability I'll do this
using known results and once I'm done
with this then I can construct and
describe soundness of the measurement
protocol okay before I get into the
measurement protocol I'll just remind
you about standard and how tumor basis
measurements because I'll be using this
so if you start with a single qubit
state sign a standard basis measurement
results in a bit B with probability
alpha B square Hadamard measurement
consists of applying hanuman transform
to the state which is ultimate and then
measuring in the standard basis
okay so now I can go into the
measurement protocol the goal of the
measurement protocol is to use
interaction to force the prover to
behave as the verifiers trusted
measurement device so in this side I
have the model which I've talked about
this is a classical verify a quantum
prover and they're interactive here I
have a verifier with the trusted
measurement device which enables the
verifier to perform either Hadamard or
standard basis measurements
I'd like to use interaction to force the
prover to essentially just create a
quantum state of his choice and measure
in the basis desired by the verifier and
if I can force him to behave like this
this is equivalent to the verifier
holding his own measurement device
okay so when you have a protocol like
this what's the first issue that would
come out
it's an adaptive ities so if the prover
is supposed to do the measurement for
the verifier he of course doesn't have
to fix a quantum state and measure it in
the basis chosen by the verifier he can
pick different he can just pick a
different distribution for each
measurement request by the verifier so
maybe he never even held a quantum state
and he instead uses classical
distributions for every possible query
by the verifier so when I define the
measurement protocol which I'll do now
this is the main thing that I need to
take care I need to ensure that there
exists a quantum state underlying the
measurement distribution obtained by the
verifier
so this is the soundness so for a
measurement protocol I'll say it's sound
if it satisfies this condition if the
verifier accepts there exists a quantum
state which I'm calling Rho which is
independent of the verifiers measurement
choice which underlies the measurement
results yeah so it's basically you're
doing a device independence that you can
write with what you're saying it's sort
of you're assuming the correctness of
quantum mechanics or what does it mean
that you're saying that there exists a
quantum state assuming it seems like we
had the whole thing does assume quantum
the validity of quantum mechanics fine
yeah because in order to prove this I
need to characterize how the proof is
behaving so I say he follows the
protocol and then he applies a unitary
operator so I'm assuming the crack
I mean like if you could make approver
able to make multiple non collapsing
measurements that it could surely cheat
in this protocol okay so now let me
formalize this so in this side with the
interactive proof you have approver P
and the verifier chooses a basis choice
H so this is represented by an N bit
string there's one of two bases for each
qubit and at the end of this interactive
protocol the verifier ends with the
distribution which all index by the
prover P and the basis choice H now what
I want to say is that this distribution
is equivalent to the distribution which
had would have been obtained by
measuring a fixed quantum state row in
the basis choice indicated by H so this
is formally stated here if the prover is
accepted with high probability then
there exists a state row such that for
all basis choices H these two
distributions are computationally
indistinguishable
so this is this is proving my what I
wanted to show that there exists a
quantum state underlying the
distribution obtained by the merit I'm
sorry but it's not it's not saying there
actually exists if what I'm saying it's
saying that there's a quantum state
where would have been hard to
distinguish yeah yeah so that's it
that's a big part of it well you
couldn't you can't tell whether it
exists leads to that those results
you're not assumed I mean the approver
could be under the computational
assumption yes there does exist the
quantum state under the exist and this
is good enough a quantum state
mathematically exists that's consistent
with that and we're never concluding
that the prover holds it well under a
computational assumption you might
actually even thinkable and be station
right you would need a computational
assumption that would separate quantum
from classical to get the gut to such a
conclusion and I guess you're not making
such an exception
oh right way more than me you can do it
without Jeff all right
this is the measurement protocol so what
I've done so far as I said that I've
defined a measurement protocol so it's a
protocol between a classical computer
and a quantum computer which satisfies
this model so it's equivalent to this
model in which the verifier has a
trusted measurement device and the
prover is just sending over a stateroom
so now I'm back to the model which I
keep which came up earlier in the talk
in which the verify has some quantum
device to help them so now all I need to
show is that in this model where the
verifier has this trusted measurement
device quantum computations can be
verified and this is already known yeah
so this is already known but I'm gonna
I'll cover it now but this is not
okay so to cover this let's go back to
classical verification for a second to
verify an efficient classical
computation one thing that can be done
is that the verifier receipt has some
instance of a problem which he wants to
verify he reduces it to a 3sat instance
asks approver for a satisfying
assignment and verifies that the
instance is satisfied I can draw an
analogy to this and a quant in the
quantum setting where 3sat the 3sat
problem corresponds to the local
Hamiltonian problem an n-bit variable
assignment X corresponds to an N cubed
quantum state the number of unsatisfied
clauses corresponds to the energy of the
quantum state with respect to the
Hamiltonian so given this analogy the
verifier can verify an efficient quantum
computation by reducing the instance to
a local Hamiltonian instance H asking
the prover for a ground state and
verifying that the ground state has low
energy with respect to H now if the
instance is in the language then there
will exist a state with low energy and
if not all states will have sufficiently
high energy so let me just give a bit
more detail about how the verify would
verify that a state has low energy a
local Hamiltonian H can be written as a
sum over terms H I where each H is local
it acts on it at most two qubits and we
know that to measure with respect to H I
only had a Mart and standard basis
measurements are required so when the
verifier estimates the energy with
respect to h he only has to perform
Hadamard and standard basis measurements
okay given this I can go back to this
model and say how the verifier would
verify that some instances in the
language for bqp
the prover sends over the state road to
the verifier the verifier chooses a term
of the hamiltonian at random and then he
measures the energy with respect to that
term using only his Hadamard and
standard basis measurement device it's
not the only thing that I would have to
do to use my measurement protocol for
verification is to plug in my
measurement protocol in place of this
trusted measurement device
so that's all so this is this is how the
measurement protocol links to
verifiability and now I can get more
into the measurement protocol but this
might be a good time for questions so
good it seems like if you just wanted to
prove let's say that the prover had
quantum power forget about you know the
output of this particular computation
right using this basic Clough
reconstruction you know can we not do
that because you know we say you know
force the the approver to make the
superposition measure and then you
challenge the prover to do one of two
things right okay good good good so-so
but then randomness but also that there
was long you know under the
computational assumption that the prover
really held a quantum state the quantum
state didn't just play tonically exist
the prover helped the prover helped it
yeah and the computational assumption
holds under do we not conclude that the
prover literally held this immunity
you really need to create a state and
apply one state and measure including
the basis that make some angle for that
you can also ask the proven fact oh
right if you just want to see the second
P you know I know this thing in
particular does that right the
disability to return you know either
x0 or x1 or else though how can we know
right is a quantum ability right it's a
but somehow that's not what you're using
here I am using that but I need to
extend it right because I don't just
want an arbitrary quantum state I want
this specific ground state in
yeah
I think so the computational thing is
saying that it could be some actually
look at a really different one today not
just unitarily equivalent but it's one
that has kind of the same same effect
computation right because all I'm trying
to verify seven instances in the
language right so if it's
computationally indistinguishable that
means this ground state test can't
distinguish between it right so that's
still verifying that the instances in
the language so specifically it's enough
for what I'm trying to do but for
example in the randomness setting it
wouldn't be enough meaning a quantum
adversary can't distinguish yeah well so
this computational indistinguishability
it's it works in certain settings and
not in others depending on what you want
right like for the randomness paper we
needed information theoretic randomness
right works you in this sufficient
resources that some distribution is
computationally indistinguishable from
another distribution that doesn't give
you any guarantee so if what you're
interested in is entropy guarantees you
need statistical distribution that's
different
okay so now that I've linked the
measurement protocol to verifiability
I'm gonna spend the rest of the talk
talking about the measurement protocol
how its constructed and how I prove
soundness the first thing I have to do
is go back to trapdoor coffre functions
so in order to use them for the
measurement protocol I need a little bit
more structure so instead of just a
single function which is two to one I'll
have a pair of functions F 0 and F 1
which are injective and have the same
image the reason that I need this
function is because I don't want an
honest prover to just create a random
superposition over a cloth I want him to
be able to entangle his state with the
cloth because remember he's picking a
state of his choice let's call it row
and the verifier wants him to force
wants to force him to do something to
that state so this is just adding
structure and it enables him to entangle
a state with a cloth I'll tell you how
to do this in a second but the effect is
that there's just a single qubit States
I he can entangle it with a random cloth
and you can think of this as an encoding
of the states I since the prover doesn't
know the law so he's done some
transformation to the state but he
doesn't quite know what it looks like
the reason this is useful is because
once the prover reports Y to the
verifier the verifier now has leverage
over the prover state so the prover got
to choose the states i but the verifier
knows what the encoding is an approver
doesn't now how do you do this so the
first the verifier generates a trapdoor
a claw free function pair s0 f 1 he
hangs on to the trapdoor and he sends
over the function to that proofer
related to each other
they're just so before I had one
function which is two to one now I have
two separate functions which are
injected with the same image okay the
verifier generates a TCS and the chapter
and now the honest prover uses this to
entangle a single qubit of his choice
with the clock so we first just starts
with a single qubit state sigh he does
the same thing where he creates a
uniform superposition over X but now he
chooses which function to apply based on
the qubit his single qubit and when he
does this and he measures this to obtain
Y then it collapses to the encoding that
I told you earlier
and now the prover reports why to the
verifier and the verifier uses a
trapdoor to extract the two pre-image
sfy at this point once the verifier
receives why he chooses either to test
the prover or to delegate measurements
so to request a Hadamard or standard
basis measurements measurement in the
case of a test the verify just requests
a pre-image of y if the prover was
honest this is the state he holds he can
measure it in the standard basis he'll
obtain a pre-image and the point of this
is now the verifiers controlled the
provers behavior to a very small extent
so he knows that the prover applied the
function and holds a pre image of the
function
this is the point of the test round yeah
oh he just created any single qubit
state of his choice so he created that
single qubit state yeah if the story is
a contract whatever state you want the
state that creates is supposed to be
your witness for the variety of the
vegetation oh so y'all faster okay
whatever the ground state okay and can
you remind me what's the connection here
to the local Hamilton an instance that
we're trying to verify the connection is
that the prove are supposed to be
constructing the ground state I'm just
doing this to simplify but yeah so
technically this would be a much larger
state it'd be an N cubed state and he
would be doing this process for each of
n qubits but I'm just dealing with one
qubit right now
wait but but even each Cupid considered
by itself isn't some mixed age so so
it's not a super position by itself but
because he can just do this okay so
he'll have an N qubit state and you'll
have n different functions and you just
thought to us all of them at once and
reports n Weiss and then I can apply
this analysis to each qubit separately
because what the analysis does is it
doesn't control the previous state but
it controls the deviation
guess what it's made me do to the
independence between all of them
different functions so all the N
functions are picked independently
okay so this is the point of the test
that the verifiers controlled the
previous behavior to some extent now how
do you delegate how to mark basis
measurements so the goal here is the
prover should be able to apply a Hana
Mart transform to his state and measure
it because that's what the verify wants
to see he wants to see the Hadamard
measurement of the state the problem
here is that due to the encoding there
is no interference so when you have X 0
and X 1 now it's hard to perform a hat
on our transform the solution to this is
to get rid of the interference yeah ok
the interfere with interference yeah ok
so X 0 and X 1 prevent interference and
the solution is to apply the Hadamard
transform to the entire state and
measure the second register which gets
rid of this issue ok so what this does
is it results in a different encoding so
when the Hadamard transform is performed
on this state and it's measured to
obtain some string D then it results in
a different encoding which looks like
this so now you have the state h sy
which is what you wanted to get
initially but it's off by a bit slip
operator so X is just a classical bit
flip applied in superposition and this
bit flip operator is a function of the
claw and the string D
and okay so now this is the honest
protocol for applying a hat amide
measurement the previous starts with an
encrypted stateside he finds a hat of my
transform to the entire state he obtains
the measurement D the string D and he
obtains a measurement for the first
qubit and now the verifier decodes
because the verifier has to strip off
the spit flip operator
so are there questions n plus one yeah
yeah yeah so you're doing H to the whole
thing and D results from measuring the
second register after the hazard
so this is the honest application of the
Hadamard transform
so what is the Mariner gift
forever gets a string D which is the
result of the Hadamard measurement of
that second register and he also gets a
bit let's call it B and what he does and
the bit B is a result of measuring the
first qubit and Hadamard basis and what
he does is he takes the bit B and he X
oars it with this and that has the
effect of stripping off that bit flip
operator and so now the verifiers final
bit stored is M but that's the result of
a decoding honestly this is really like
major week yeah yeah exactly but if you
behave dishonestly then I can take
advantage of this and that's what I'll
do later I'll take advantage of the fact
that the prover doesn't know the
decoding
so that's what you're not going to show
white security No so what I'll show now
so so far all I've done is a hat or mind
measurement and the next thing I need to
tell you is how to do a standard basis
measurement and once I do that then I
can start telling you why it's secure so
far what I've shown is how the verifier
would delegate Hadamard measurement to
do this he sends over a trapdoor a claw
free function f 0 F 1 the proven reports
why the verifier chooses either to test
or to request a Hadamard measurement now
remember the soundness guarantee I need
there to exist a quantum state
independent of the verifiers measurement
choice which underlies the distribution
obtained by the verifier that means when
I try to delegate a standard basis
measurement the prover shouldn't be able
to tell that I'm delegating a standard
basis measurement so I can do something
simple like just ask him for a standard
basis measurement here that wouldn't
work because then he could distinguish
and then he could change his
distribution dependent on the basis
choice requested by the verifier so what
I need to ensure is that the provers
messages are computationally
indistinguishable when the verify
requests a standard basis measurement
yeah be aware that I'm asking for that
measurements to me
you know what I actually asked sure yeah
but in this protocol specifically he's
being told at this round Hadamard her
standard so what he could do is he could
pick a distribution for each basis and
report it when he's asked right so this
is after the test so I test him once
just to test the format and then I ask
him for how to murder standard and if he
knows which one then he can pick a
distribution yeah but presumably that
could be a protocol which doesn't
okay so what I'll show next is that to
delegate standard basis measurements the
verifier only needs to change the first
message and he changes the first message
in a way that it's computationally
indistinguishable to the prover so all
he does is he replaces the functions F 0
F 1 with some different functions G 0 G
1 which are computationally
indistinguishable to the prover and what
these functions are are instead of so
before F 0 and F 1 were trapdoor law
free functions they were injective and
they had the same image G 0 G 1 will be
injective but their images will not
overlap at all and I need the guarantee
that the functions F 0 F 1 and G 0 G 1
are computationally indistinguishable
now the point of this is if the prover
encodes with G 0 G 1 this has the effect
of standard basis measurement so what's
happening here this is the same thing as
before where he applies a function in
superposition but now when he measures
this since the images of the function do
not overlap this part of the
superposition will collapse
just applying this encoding results in a
standard basis measurement and the
prover does not know that he did a
standard basis measurement and the
important part here is that when he
responds to the verifier with image y
the verifier can actually extract the
standard basis measurement because he
can invert the function y and determine
whether the pre image comes from g 0 or
g 1
okay so this is a standard basis
protocol and the standard basis protocol
the verifier just sends over g0 g1 the
preview reports why the verifier asked
to test or Hadamard measurement but now
the verifier can extract the standard
basis measurement from Y so he can
ignore whatever the proofer does in the
Hadamard measurement okay are there any
questions
so I'm still missing you know we're
verifying not just that there is a
quantum state but that that quantum
state is the ground state okay
measurement protocol only verifies that
there's a quantum state then I plug it
in to this QM a type protocol no I did
that was earlier so this is when I said
that the measurement protocol links to
verifiability and that's just saying
that there exists a quantum state with
low energy so as soon as I say the proof
is creating a quantum state then I can
say if the instance is in the language
there exists the state otherwise he
can't do anything to pass so the thing
I'm getting around is him just creating
distributions which don't correspond to
quantum states I say so the prover
really trusts trying to convince the
verifier that there is a clock so the
answer to a QM a prop I mean this
problem this one worked for QA because
of the computational assumptions but yes
it's alright but if you tried to extend
the prover to me and then yeah yeah the
restriction about it give me instead of
a gaming machine at least all
competition is industry in
distinguishability okay right yes is a
humane machine could break morning with
us proofer is a bqp machine that gets in
addition to kill them a witness right
and then you know that it seems
something about it by States right like
you'd have to assume that learning with
errors is secure in the presence of a
state created by a QA adversary I think
that's okay right you get a quantum
advice and that'll you should still be
hard right right yeah but if I give you
a superposition of the samples of nwe
then you can take the W well it's
independent it's independent of the ILWU
instance
[Music]
so is it true that in that sense is like
a survey right if the premier had many
copies of the qma witness state then you
could do this and he was a bqp burger
because there's amplification yeah if
you just have one you only have an
inverse polynomial gap and that's not
good
returning by the preimage and that the
part about equation like inner product
so if unity test is really to spit you
can find agreement when you ask
okay so this is the recap of the
measurement protocol the goal is to use
the prover as a blind verifiable
measurement device the verifier selects
the basis choice either had I'm under
standard if it's Hadamard he sends over
trapped or claw free functions if it's
standard he sends over chapter or
injective functions the prover encodes
the state reports Y the verifier chooses
either to test or to request a Hadamard
measurements okay so this is a full
protocol and the next thing I'll talk
about is soundness so if there are any
more questions about the protocol it's a
good time to strip away the the X 0 of X
or X 1 Y a line whether you're doing it
yeah right yeah yeah that's pretty
important the standard and how to mine
okay so again you know we're in this
vertical is the verifier consulting his
local Hamiltonian okay so he runs this
protocol and at the end he's guaranteed
that his measurement distribution comes
from a quantum state and then he uses a
Hamiltonian test to analyze the
measurement distribution and determine
the energy of the state no no I mean
yeah yeah let me
she's trying to say the proper kind of
state yeah and the bear fur wish means
he wished he could have measured it with
the XX or ZZ operators it could yeah
then he would have been able to estimate
the energy and that's all night stirred
it so the measurement protocol just
guarantees that this is what he's doing
even though he doesn't have access to
trying to keep track of something energy
is mentioned but is energy being used
for any purpose other than quantum
science
satisfiability just used it then so it's
just what whether the state satisfies
tests or not the amount of energy
otherwise just doesn't matter it's not
really
it does in the same sense that it
matters in Q&A it's not it's not just
Fred didn't me not be frustration-free
there's a gal satisfiability basic does
there exist the state such that these xx
+ ZZ measurements return this energy
that is a cue I'm a complete problem so
it's a it's a special case of two local
okay so yeah that's just explore owns so
what no because he can kill me
amplification so he can just use many
copies
huh to do something it means a lot of
attractive forces just into a dishonest
interpretation
it's a business arguments and stuff
right
okay so this is um so so far I presented
this protocol and it seems like it might
be sound but it turns out it's only
sound if you have certain hard core bit
properties which are satisfied by the
function so here I'm gonna give you a
counter example of why things would
break down if these hard core bits were
not satisfied but I'll go through it
relatively quickly and if people are
interested I'll stay on it otherwise
I'll move on
funny okay so the cheating strategy that
we were trying to avoid is that the
prover creates a different distribution
for the standard basis and the Hadamard
basis meaning there is no quantum state
underlying the measurements he reports
so I'll show that this is possible if
these hardcore bit properties are not
satisfied so recall a cheating strategy
the prover fixes two bits
BH and BS BH is supposed to be reported
for the Hadamard basis and BS is
reported for the standard basis and he
fixes these bits so that they pass
whatever whatever Hamiltonian test the
verifier wants to do later okay now
assume that there's a claw x0 x1 and a
string D for which the prover knows both
x BS so this is one member of the claw
corresponding to the bit es es 0 he
knows x0 pieces 1 he knows x1 and he
also knows this d x0 plus x1 so this
violates the earlier hard core a bit but
here I'm assuming that doesn't hold and
showing how he could cheat so if he
knows both of these values then he can
ensure that when the verifier receives a
measurement results for the standard
basis he obtains bs and for the Hadamard
basis he obtains BH no that's that's
what I'm gonna show now he can't tell
but he can still do it
so I'm saying blindness isn't enough for
verifiability you need the hardcore bit
okay so to compute why that he reports
to the verify the prover just evaluates
the received function on X BS so in the
case he received F he evaluates it and
for G he evaluates it now for the
standard basis and so when aspera had in
mind measurement the prover just reports
the string D for which he knows the
inner product and he reports a B H X or
a DX e XR 1 now for the standard basis
the verify was just going to invert Y so
he's gonna store xbs through the
hidamari basis he's gonna look at this
thing this bit reported by the proven
and he's going to XOR it with this so
he'll obtain BH so now the verifier
obtains exactly what the prover wanted
him to obtain
and the prover did not have to
compromise blindness he only had to know
this hardcore bit if there are questions
I can stay on it otherwise I can move on
all this example is showing is that
blindness is not enough for
verifiability and that the hardcore bits
really are crucial to make this protocol
work okay so now since I said that the
intuition the first step we need for
proving soundness is these two hardcore
bit properties the first one is the one
that I just mentioned so it's just
saying it's computationally difficult to
compute both addi which satisfies this
equation and one of the two pre images
and the other one is a little different
it's saying there exists a string d such
that for all claws that bit is the same
bit so it doesn't vary over the
different costs and it's computationally
difficult to guess that bit this didn't
come up in the counter example it seems
a bit more unnatural but it's needed in
the proof
okay I it's not necessary to fully
understand both of these yeah
I know it's just as long as it exists
just one yeah
okay so now how to prove soundness to go
into this I'll talk about the two
previous models which I talked about in
which the model was relaxed a little bit
the key step in both of these models was
enforcing some structure in the prover
state meaning enforcing that the prover
holds a state and then controlling how
he uses that state so first day how that
was done and then say roughly how I can
do it in my protocol remember lower the
FK seventeen these oh okay because the
the soundness proofs and both of the
initial results were incorrect to
varying degrees yeah
so in this model where the verifier
holds a quantum computer enforcing the
structure of the state is relatively
easy because the verifier can just
encode qubits and send them over now he
knows what the previous initial state
looks like since he created it and then
he can use this knowledge to track the
pervert throughout the protocol in the
to prover model it's a little bit more
difficult the verifier plays a game with
approvers based on their winning
probability he says that they hold
certain states they actually hold bell
pairs and based on this then he can say
that the provers behave in a certain way
throughout the rest of the protocol you
needed error correcting codes to fix the
proofs of the ABA and the FK results
well error correcting codes were already
there in the protocol the soundness in
the in der eats paper the soundness
protocols were wrong but the protocols
were mostly correct
okay so now how do I do this this
enforcing structure step how do I do it
in my protocol I don't have a quantum
computer there's no extra pervert to
play a game with so the first step is
I'll use the test round of the
measurement protocol as a starting point
so what the test round guaranteed was
that the prover applied the function in
some manner manner because he held a
pre-image so that's saying at some point
in time the prover state has to be in a
superposition over the pre images of the
point y that he reported so this is a
very weak statement just saying at some
point in time I know his state looked
something like this like this is just a
bunch of extra space but I know in some
register he held a pre image and now I
want to take this statement and
bootstrap it up to say that actually
he's holding a full quantum state so how
do I do this this is where the decoding
comes in and the decoding is very
crucial first the prover okay we can
assume the prover starts with a state
like this and in fact point he's
supposed to apply a Hadamard but let's
say instead he deviates from the
protocol deviation can be modeled by an
arbitrary unitary operator you so he
applies an arbitrary operator you to the
state but now when the verifier receives
the measurement remember he's decoding
with this DX 0 plus X 1 so this means
the unitary u is its conjugated by two
different forms of computational
randomness which are unknown to the
prover this is one form the decoding and
the other form is that pre image
register what's the prover doesn't know
is that the Pardo's at the image right
but maybe the quantum state that he's
actually has maybe
but somewhere in his state there's a
pre-image
that's the question of the addition this
is pretty much exactly what's written
over there the same thing is that's
written is that saying that the prover
has a state and in some way on that
stage is really you know your answer
okay so this is saying that this unitary
you is kind of randomized by two
different forms of computational
randomness this is a very common thing
that comes up in interactive proofs and
it's called the poly twirl and it's
saying that if you're unitary you is
conjugated by randomness then you can
simplify the unitary significantly like
in the strongest form you can take the
unitary and just reduce it to a poly
operator which is very simple to take
care of so here my issue is that I don't
have that structure I have some
computational randomness but in order to
use it I'd have to convert the
computational randomness into some form
like some form in which I can use it for
the poly twirl and once I do that then I
can use it to simplify this deviation
you so to do that I rely on this is
computational the poly twirl really has
to be information theoretic right so I
have to take and it's not even quite the
pally torille because because the prover
controls D so it's not it's not a random
decoding chosen by the berry it's
adversarially chosen so in order to
convert this to a poly twirl I have to
use the hardcore bit properties so I use
the hardcore bit properties to argue
that this really is a poly twirl a very
elementary version of a lead or yeah
oh yeah okay um so if you have no no it
doesn't if you have a unitary acting so
you have some state and it's encoded by
a random poly operator this is a bit
shift and this is a face this is a
quantum analog of the one-time pad so
this is a random operator and like in
the paper with doreet the verifier just
performs this encoding so he picks a
random poly and he applies it to the
state and the approver deviates and when
the verifier receives the state he again
decodes this is called the poly twirl
when you have a unitary u which is
conjugated by two men and poly operators
and when you have this then you can take
this and average it over the randomness
of the poly operator and say that this
essentially cuts down the unitary you to
just act as a poly operator which is a
very simple form of deviation and can
then be handled pretty easily
and here I'm just trying to take this
idea the fact that if you have a unitary
and it's conjugated by some randomness
which is independent of the unitary then
you can simplify it so I'm saying my
randomness is these claws and the
hardcore bit so you say any operation
that is applied on an encrypted stage
yeah in my case it can be weaker but
it's enough yeah well why is that I mean
it seems like you could still be
anything right after the decoding we can
see that it could have been anything
well it's randomized by the decoding oh
yeah but once it's randomized then then
it's not even a poly we could just say
you know even stronger than that without
loss of generality it's the identity no
no it would be the identity if you took
this away but because of the because of
both of them you don't just get the
identity you essentially what happens is
a unit area has cross terms acting on
the state but if it's randomized by this
you just get rid of all the cross terms
and so you just have a convex I'm over
pal the operators acting on the state
okay so I want to use the poly twirl but
my difficulty is converting this
computational randomness into a form in
which can it can be used for the torille
and to do that I rely on the hardcore
bit properties so this is why they're so
crucial that's it so I showed that
verifiable secure delegation of quantum
computations is possible with a
classical machine I'm relying on quantum
secure trapdoor claw free functions
which can be built built from learning
with errors I use this function to first
characterize the initial space of the
prover and then I strengthen the claw
free property to complete the
characterization and prove the existence
of a quantum state were you just like
going over and explaining it in a
different way
no I was defining the protocol and
saying what I want right already sort of
said why there has to be a global state
and then you kind of did it again I
didn't say why there I said if there is
a global state and I can use QM a
verification techniques to verify but I
didn't say why yeah so the whole ending
part was to say why there has to be a
global statement
a function that you construct in this
paper isn't the same as the one it's the
same construction but I have to extend
it because I also need these injective
functions so I also build the injective
functions and then I need another
trapdoor
I need another hard core bit property
but the hard core bit property I use
their construction but I just um proof
[Applause]
suppose the original computation for the
original computation are you talking
about the computation to construct the
history state so all he's doing is he's
constructing the history state and then
he's encoding it by applying a function
in superposition that's it
so that's just the conversion from the
original circuit to constructing the
history state in what terms what do you
mean time speed how much in unity
because you could clock the basic answer
is it's polynomial
[Laughter]
[Applause]